now chris paul
tangled up with wesley matthews
underneath
and uh chris paul i don't think that was
a dirty i don't think that was a dirty
play that's just
physical basketball common fouls
there's a bum bump bump this is
significant though because you never see
chris paul just lay on no
he's not one of those guys who gets shot
every game no it's uh
later all good
uh he went in the back and got some
treatment everything
um is
not up in the air i don't want to give
an official update on him until i get
more information i don't have anything
right now but
when i talked to him when he came back
out he said he still had his strength
and um he seems to be okay but we want
to wait until tomorrow
you know after he wakes up and then our
medical team can make an assessment but
he he told me that he felt like he had
his strength
and and that's a good thing he'd been
fighting through that shoulder injury
for the first
three games of the series looked good in
game four and now
holding it again here in game five shaq
came out pretty strong about what the
lakers did not do in this game
chuckster the lakers don't have anthony
davis they're gonna lose
i said that the other night say it
tonight don't say it tomorrow
lakers are not going to win this year
without anthony davis he
if you go back and look at them last
year in the bubble it was a toss-up who
was going to get mvp
in the finals that's how great of a
player anthony davis is
unfortunately he's always hurt and now
you have to factor in uh the nba is
gonna have to make a decision
about the future of the nba
at some point these guys gonna have to
get some rest
you know between the bubble shortening
season
uh quick turnaround a lot of guys
getting hurt that's a fact i understand
we need to play games
because everybody's losing some money
well the tv networks
but at some point basketball is hard on
your body
and if you don't have time to heal
you're always going to keep getting hurt
and the davis has a history of getting
hurt and now
it's compounded with a shorter season
and now
playing every other day i don't think
he's going to be ready to play thursday
nobody pulls a hamstring or pulls a
groin and get better in four to eight
hours you know i was surprised
they had him warming up before the game
i know you said last night you didn't
even think he should make the trip he
should have been in l.a again
treatment why would you have him
warm up and aggravate or growing i just
don't understand that at all
that makes zero sense draymond is a
contemporary player what do you have to
say about what chuck is talking about
with injuries i know you guys
didn't play in the bubble last year but
a lot of teams did and then had that
quick turnaround
so so when you hear him say that what do
you say
i think he makes a great point when you
when you look at this season you had a
lot of injuries hamstrings
poor groins but you also had acl tears
you know a lot of those things are
fatigue related
and so anthony davis says he as he hit
on
he has had a history of injuries you
know lebron got hurt obviously that was
a freak accident but you've had so many
guys going down the injury
and now this season will end for most
people
at some point in june possibly july
and then you're talking about starting
camp back in september
with olympics in there it's a lot of
basketball so it's definitely something
to think about
uh but at the end of the day you know
what they say if it don't make dollars
don't make sense shaq
great points thanks for that
when we come back give him a break ernie
he's playing hurt too yeah i know he is
that percocet wearing down